[Musique]
plusieurs jours une personnalité fait
couler beaucoup d'encre Norman ta voix
était placé en garde à vue interrogée
pour des accusations de viol et
corruption de mineurs plusieurs jeunes
fans témoignent contre la star internet
parmi ces victimes présumées Selma venu
témoigner la semaine dernière sur notre
plateau ce qui savait que vous avez 14
ans oui
bien sûr à la suite de plusieurs
plaintes l'homme avait été placé en
garde à vue lundi dernier avant d'être
libéré mais l'enquête reste toujours en
cours et le vidéaste qui avait déjà été
lâché par sa plateforme webedia vient de
subir une nouvelle sanction YouTube
démonétises la chaîne de Norman Thavaud
concrètement il y a donc plus de
publicités associées à sa chaîne et le
youtubeur ne touche désormais plus de
revenus publicitaires alors les vidéos
de Norman finalement démonétisée par
YouTube comprenez-vous cette décision
alors allez on va faire vite là dessus
également qui dit non qui dit oui je
veux un nom un oui donc un nom ah non on
a qui on a Richard Cocciante moi
j'aimerais bien que ça aille vite pour
les pour les procès comme ça parce qu'on
sait pas s'il est coupable en fait tu
vois on sait pas alors moi je dis
toujours quand il y a une deux et trois
filles quatre filles à mon avis il y a
un loup il y a quelque chose de pas
clair mais ça c'est tu l'empêche de
bouffer un mec tu tapes sur son taf en
fait empêcher de bouffer c'est peut-être
pas bon pour beaucoup d'oseille de côté
j'en sais rien mais mine de rien tu lui
arrête son taf c'est c'est ça me gêne
quand tu es pas coupable en fait quand
tu es coupable je suis sans pitié il y a
pas il y a pas de problème mais quand tu
es pas encore coupable et que tu es pas
passé devant le tribunal il y a beaucoup
de gens qui ont dit comme comme Raymond
si vous en pensez qu'il verra je trouve
que c'est une décision intelligente
parce que c'est vrai aucune charge n'a
été retenu contre lui bien sûr l'enquête
mais je trouve que YouTube prend les
devants c'est pour ça que je trouve que
c'est subtil il démonétise il
n'interdisent pas ils sont obligés de
réagir quand même parce que ils savent
que le dossier est potentiellement lourd
si ils ne font rien après on va leur
dire tout le monde savait vous n'avez
rien fait et là je trouve là j'ai le
dossier lourd et pas la justice la
justice le sait puisque l'enquête se
poursuit non mais je sens que c'est une
décision intelligente Cyril ne pas
interdire les vidéos mais prendre déjà
entre guillemets une première sanction
au cas où je trouve ça malin voilà bah
pas moi c'est ce que vous pensez aussi
d'accord oui Jean-Marie ben moi je pense
que le pourquoi te dire oui Jean-Marie
comme si j'allais encore faire chier
vas-y crache ton venin vas-y crache ta
balle d'or une fois je suis que j'étais
d'accord avec Gilles au départ de dire
que comme il n'a pas été jugé c'est
dommage que facebook tu veux que YouTube
tout d'un coup se mette entre les deux
et puis décide de prendre une sanction
alors que il n'a pas lui-même été jugé
par par la justice ça c'est une une
chose évidente donc est-ce que on a le
droit est-ce qu'une plateforme a le
droit de rendre la justice dans ce pays
ou pas quoi
c'est à dire que tout d'un coup bah lui
alors le fait qu'il gagne plus d'argent
ça va aller je pense pour lui mais tu
vois c'est pas comme si on enlevait le
travail et quelqu'un justement qui par
exemple travaille sur un marché
aujourd'hui il y a pas longtemps mais
c'est pas la même chose quand même merci
c'est un peu le même principe ce qui
s'est passé avec avec Arya habitant en
fait on lui coupait aussi un peu le truc
du film avant donc je sais pas que je
suis forcément d'accord c'est
qu'aujourd'hui en France ça se fait
comme ça c'est pour ça que je pense que
pour les personnalités ça devrait aller
plus vite non pas parce que c'est les
passes droites ça devrait aller plus
vite parce que et ça impacte le côté
juridique et ça impacte de manière
significative le côté professionnel plus
l'impact public donc en fait on est
triplement accusé quand on a un problème
comme ça en tant que personne n'a été
publique